Sarah Jessica Parker is heartbroken over
Kim Cattrall's comments about their
friendship just heartbroken
[Music]
the divorced are stopped by watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen on
Wednesday night and opened up about her
former Sex in the City co-star who not
only decided not to return for the third
movie we've never been friends but also
dismiss their friendship during an
October 2017 interview with Piers Morgan
I don't know I was really I found it
very upsetting because that's you know
that's not the way I recall our
experience it was a professional
experience but it came it became
personal because it was years and years
of our lives so I'm hoping that that
sort of eclipses anything that's been
recently spoken when Cohen suggested
Sharon Stone replace cotrol Parker
didn't hate it I think it's a really
interesting idea yeah
et caught up with Parker in January and
she weighed in on the possibility of a
Sex in the City 3 I mean I struggle with
it because it's you know it's a it's a
bit sad but better there are one must
keep these things in perspective and I
have a lot of incredible memories
singular memories that that are shared
among that those four women and I'm
incredibly grateful for the experience
[Music]